hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
it was the problem that left some of the
smartest math students in the state
stumped
and was described as one of the hardest
problems they ever encountered reports
palovey single in the sydney morning
herald
this problem was given to 17 year old
students in australia
i tried it and honestly i would not have
solved it in an exam
i benefited from a video explanation by
philip liang who was the top student in
the state
i encourage you to check out the video
and there's a clickable link in the
video description
so what was the problem
in triangle abc
point d is chosen on side a b and point
e is chosen on side ac so that d e is
parallel to b c
and b c divided by de is equal to the
square root of 2.
the process is repeated two more times
point f is chosen on side bc and point g
is chosen on side b a so that fg is
parallel to ca and ca divided by fg is
equal to the square root of 2.
point h is chosen on side cb and point i
is chosen on side ca so that h i is
parallel to b a and b a divided by h i
is equal to the square root of two
the segments f g and h i intersect at x
d e and h i intersect at y and d e and f
g intersect at z
there are two parts to this question
first
prove that d y is equal to z e
and second find the exact value of the
ratio yz divided by bc
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so let's get started with the diagram we
need to prove that d y is equal to z e
now one of the reasons this problem is
complicated is because it's a little bit
of an alphabet suit so one of the
benefits of making a video is that i can
focus on just the parts that matter for
any particular step
so let's get started by focusing just on
these two triangles
the first thing i will claim is a
triangle bfg is similar to triangle bca
this is because both triangles share the
common angle b
and their other angles are equal because
they are corresponding angles of
parallel lines gf and ac
next
we have that bc divided by bf is equal
to the square root of 2.
this is because the triangles are
similar and it's given that ac divided
by gf is equal to the square root of 2.
now we're going to do the same sort of
thing with another set of triangles
here we have the triangle chi
is similar to triangle cba
why is that
well they share a common angle c and the
other angles are equal because
h i and a b are given to be parallel
so we now can conclude that bc divided
by hc is equal to square root of 2.
that's because the triangles are similar
and we were given that b a divided by h
i is equal to the square root of 2.
so what can we do with this
well we have two different fractions
that are equal to the square root of 2
so they must be equal to each other
furthermore
their numerators are both bc
this means their denominators must also
be equal
so we have hc is equal to bf
now we're going to go back to our
original diagram
the next thing to notice is that this
shape d y h b is a parallelogram
that's because the opposite sides are
given to be parallel from the given
information
we will also have that z e c f is a
parallelogram for the same sort of
reason
so now we start out that d y is equal to
b h because they're opposite sides of a
parallelogram
then bh is equal to bc minus hc
we just prove that bf is equal to hc so
this is equal to bc minus bf
but bc minus bf is equal to fc
and then fc is equal to ze because
they're opposite sides of a
parallelogram
so we've proven that dy is equal to ze
and we're done with the first part of
this question
now let's go to the second part of the
question
we need to find the exact value of the
ratio yz divided by bc
so on a problem like this it's not
exactly clear how to approach it and how
to get to the end result so just start
out with some information that you do
know
well we do know that y z is equal to d e
minus d y minus z e
we just proved that d y is equal to z e
so we can then say this is equal to d e
minus two times ze
next z e is equal to fc because we have
opposite sides of a parallelogram
we can then replace fc with bc minus bf
and we're getting closer to putting
everything in terms of bc
now recall that bf is equal to bc
divided by the square root of 2 so we
can substitute that in now all we need
to do is put d e in terms of b c but
that was also given information d e is
equal to bc divided by the square root
of two
so we now factor out the b c and
simplify and we get the following
expression
we then just need to divide both sides
by bc so that we get yz divided by bc is
equal to three minus two times the
square root of two all over the square
root of two and that's our answer
did you figure it out
thanks for watching these videos
available for free on youtube build
confidence for students and inspire
mathematical discovery for viewers
around the world they have over 100
million views and we now have over 1
million subscribers thank you please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos and email me a puzzle or topic at
presh mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
merchandise and my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support